seven a guy who was on the team for a
couple of those wins back in 2003 2004
super bowls 38 and 39 the great rodney
harrison now with nbc's football night
in america hey rodney how are you buddy
good morning mike i see you've had your
full um pot of coffee
i've had no coffee i've i'm just uh you
know what i'm just excited to talk to
you and uh i've had no coffee i'm far
worse when i've had coffee
is that right i'm excited to talk to you
too hey the super bowl i was thinking of
you as i watch what the patriots defense
did to the la rams offense if i told you
before the game that bill belichick is
going to hold sean mcveigh to three
points what would you have said
i would have said you're crazy now i did
pick the patriots to win by 10 10 plus
points um i figured you know they could
um
they'll beat them but man mike that
really stunned me now there's a lot of
crazy things that happen in the game but
the fact that that defense the one that
we talked about that supposedly was too
slow and didn't have a bunch of star
players couldn't get to the quarterback
um it's just coaching and sean mcvay
came out and he said he says i got our
coach first thing he said when he hit
the podium
and you know and how does that happen we
saw last year when the eagles beat the
patriots doug peterson showed up at the
super bowl with a lot of new things
offensively things that bill belichick
hadn't seen i don't get the impression
sean mcvay went back and crafted some
new looks some new plays and if you go
to the super bowl when bill belichick
has two weeks to get ready and you're
just going to use the stuff you've used
all year and last year he's going to
know everything that you're doing and
you're not going to get him on his heels
you're not going to get him against the
ropes and you're not going to win the
game
well i think it's a learning experience
too for sean mcvay because there's a
level of arrogance with these offensive
coordinators because they feel like they
can just use their call sheet and they
can just it's about the plays belichick
makes it always about the situation and
not the plays you know what i mean and
these guys they get to a situation where
if they're struggling offensively they
don't make wholesale changes and say hey
in the second half we're going to commit
to running the football and for the life
of me you know sean mcvay show a little
transparency like we're fans we want to
know what's going on with the todd
gurley this is not the mvp todd gurley
that we're used to seeing and for him to
come out and say well you know and only
hand the ball to him i think like 10
times was absolutely ridiculous to me
you know why why do you change up and
that's why people talk about players
always talk about playoff pressure and
mike around nbc we always talk about
people changing things what they've done
like why would you only give him the
ball ten times and if he's not a hundred
percent then play somebody else so i
just i expect a little bit more
transparency from sean mcvay i i think
that that todd gurley does still have a
bad knee i think it should be a cause
for concern because he had the torn acl
back in georgia the knee is swelling up
without him being hit in the knee that's
not a good sign and and i think what
mcveigh tried to do and you tell me if
i'm wrong here not that i need to invite
you to tell me when you think i'm wrong
you do it all the time but uh when when
uh when they got ready for the super
bowl i think mcveigh was trying to sell
the idea that gurley was going to be the
centerpiece of the offense so the game
plan defensively would be take away todd
gurley
and and hey you don't need to take away
todd gurley because we're not going to
use him so i i feel like part of that
was the gamesmanship because we know
that bill belichick will always take
away what you do best i think mcveigh
was trying to convince belichick that
gurley was going to be a bigger part of
the game plan than he really was well
the the game plan from coach belichick
was still the same he was going to stop
the run he knew he was like hey we're
going to stop the run they put in that
new defense where they had like six
linemen or whatever defense alignment
across and um it was some crazy defense
that belichick probably ran back in 03
and 04 during our super bowl um
championship run but you didn't see the
adjustments you know and coach belichick
is a great coach and he's going to take
away that run game and he looks at jared
goff just like i look at jared goff and
i dare jared goff to be able to beat me
consistently for four quarters in the
super bowl it's not going to happen
and they knew that that was the case and
ronnie the one play that stands out to
me when brandon cooks pops open throws
his hand in the air like randy moss used
to and is wide open in the end zone and
first goff doesn't see him
second when he does see him he doesn't
throw that laser shot that would have
ensured a touchdown i and i i look i
don't want to i don't want to make this
a bash jared goff thing but championship
players make championship plays in
championship moments and tom brady makes
that throw jared goff doesn't make that
throw and you could argue that was the
difference between winning and losing
because if he makes that throw and it's
seven to three with 18 minutes left in
the game the whole thing could play out
a heck of a lot differently than it did
yeah momentum and positive energy and
all those different things and to me i
just felt like the patriots would win by
double digits at least by 10 points
because i just i didn't have any belief
in jared goff i knew he had played well
in the playoffs and he had shown some
signs of you know
falling apart against the bears and
things like that but i wasn't a big
believer in jared goff but you know hey
you look for the rams
you know you got knocked off by atlanta
last year you come back you make it to
the super bowl now i'm excited to see
you know i mean like what
they're going to do are they going to
bring sue back are they going to bring
peters and and akeeb and those guys
because remember mike they went all in
to win a super bowl this year and they
didn't win it
well i think some of these guys are
going to definitely be gone i think
sue's going to be gone i think dante
fowler jr is going to be gone
and i also think they're going to do
some of the things they did last year i
think there's a certain amount of
salesmanship in la rodney where they're
trying to
to re invigorate the fan base and get
those fans that that that basically went
in the direction of every other team
when there were no teams in la back to
the rams we're going to see some moves
again this year where we say wow i can't
believe they're doing that because i
think there is a certain element of
of of uh you know getting fans excited
whether or not it helps your football
team
well think about this mike i mean most
fan bases they're excited when they have
a quarterback
they're excited when they have a you
know a really great defense player well
they have a quarterback they have a
defensive player to have offensive
player to have many offensive players i
mean they're loaded so the fan base
should be excited you see progressively
kind of
the improvement that they've made over
the years and the direction in which
they're ahead i mean they can be nothing
but excited sean mcvay he just got it
handed to him on a national stage where
everybody saw the greatness of coach
belichick he's not the first he's not
going to be the last and that's just the
way it went and hopefully he can learn
from it and and use it in the future
where you know
the same results doesn't happen
well and you know i always say that
experience means so much and once the
patriots locked in is the two seed
riding it's like up here we go back to
the super bowl and they'll have another
good chance to win it but for mcveigh
right i know that the experience will
help the next time around i just wonder
if if the first taste of the super bowl
was so bad for him and so bad for jared
goff that if they do get back there in
the next few years they're going to have
flashbacks to super bowl 53 and it's
going to make it harder to overcome it i
disagree with that mike because i do
believe that getting to the super bowl
you see it you taste it you feel it you
see what the atmosphere is you say you
know what
we can do this and they play in a
division where you know seattle is
probably the what the biggest concern
um
i would say right seattle's the biggest
concern in that division so i i don't i
don't think it's one of those things
where it's going to be like shock value
oh my god we made it to super bowl we
lost and we're never going back i think
this is something that they're going to
consistently build and i agree with you
some of the players that you talk about
dante fowler to me he wasn't a game
changer and dominic and sue he's often
known when he whenever he feels like
playing he wants to play they need to
get some younger guys build them through
through the draft and so they can so you
can solidify that roster instead of
bringing all these guys in a lot of
these veteran players on one year and
two year contracts where you you're
paying them a lot of money and now you
don't know if they're going to stay
healthy et cetera do you see anything in
tom brady's game that suggests to you
he's slowing down at all
um
i don't know because when i when i said
that you know he doesn't look the same i
didn't know if his knee was bothering
him and there was reports about maybe a
mtl or a knee bothering him i don't know
because he's always been so slow and
he's actually like when i play with tom
he acts like he moves a little better
now than he did back then you know
because of his training and all his
flexibility work tom is just a very
competitive guy he he wants to play i
mean after super bowl i text him and you
know he told me some things and he's
pumped up he's excited i mean he made it
through another season um you know the
league gave him a lot of motivation
because they talked about gronk they
talked about edelman they talked about
tom so these are the things that he
looks for i mean when i play for the
patriots that's what we look for we're
number one seed and i'm talking about
hey they didn't believe in us so
we're always looking for a way to try to
get some extra motivated
but isn't that amazing and we talked
about this a lot leading up to the super
bowl with all the things that are done
the high level nutrition and the
planning and this and that that good
old-fashioned hey somebody out there
doesn't believe in us that that provides
that extra little kick to get the job
done
yeah mike and and just really thinking
about it like i'm thinking about my
career and out you know i was going into
my 15th year and i got hurt and i've if
i would not have gotten hurt you know
literally carried off the field i would
have continued to play i would have
played my 16th year if they would have
had me i would have played my 17th year
and i do believe the same thing with tom
i think tom's going to get to a point
where you're out there your football
player your mind your spirit and
everything's you know connected to
playing football and that's how you kind
of identify yourself and tom is such and
he has that competitive spirit like me
where you know you almost have to
push him off the football field in the
cart you know that's the only way i was
coming off and that's what my wife said
she said the only way i was going to get
you you know you is going to stop
playing football is if you got carried
off the football field in a car and i
did the same thing with tom because he
just loves the game so much mike
why is it that the patriots have have
figured it out when the rest of the nfl
isn't even close every year they're in
the mix eight straight years in the afc
championship game no matter how one year
ends they go back to zero and zero and
whether they've won the super bowl where
they lost it in heartbreaking fashion
they're right back at it what is it
about this organization that sets them
apart in that way they just stick to
what they do they're not you know and
the one thing i respect about coach
belichick he's not easily influenced by
any new trends and things like that to
come out all these you know new trends
and uh you know all these different
offenses and stuff like that they stick
to what they do and he teaches
fundamental football and every single
week
while i'm sitting next to you you're
typing your articles and and you know
doing your stories i keep hitting you
and i say look mike basic defense all he
has to do is knock the ball get his head
coaches teach plays they don't teach
fundamentals and i think that's where
belichick he's gotten the best of all
these other coaches throughout the
league because most of these coaches
they just offensive guys they think it's
about plays but it's really about
players and putting players in the right
position to be able to be successful
hey rodney excellent insights as always
pal we look forward to talking to you
again soon look forward to seeing you
every sunday september is going to be
here before you know it buddy enjoy the
off season we'll talk soon
all right tell your um son chris i said
hello all right
all right
there he is rodney harrison
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports